ces musiciens qui répètent
habituellement dans les studios de la
batterie de guyancourt sont réunis
devant près de 200 personnes pour un
concert un peu particulier pour cette
soirée dénommée les studios ont du coeur
aucun billet n'était en vente
il suffisait simplement de ramener un
jouet neuf j'ai emmené une barbie bas
pour l'association pour avoir le concert
show c'est une bonne initiative mais
voilà donc adjoint luthier génial ça
permet à des enfants d'avoir un noël
comme tout le monde
parrain de cette soirée caritative
johnny montreuil avec son groupe le
chanteur est venu présenter son dernier
album narvalo forever sorti en avril que
tu es là sur scène ce qu'on raconte à tu
as un truc très rock'n roll très rock
même qui peut aller vraiment tu peux
aller vraiment dans du lourd mais on
essaie vraiment de mettre toujours les
textes en avant donc il ya toujours un
petit truc sautillant il ya toujours un
gros clin d'oeil à nos grosses
références à obili à johnny cash à cette
country là en fait c'est pas la musique
country c'est un mec qui racontait des
trucs sur cette musique là parmi les
autres invités de la soirée le groupe
sugar un tiger avec didier wampas
m
pourquoi
le chanteur est un habitué de ce type
d'initiative et n'a pas hésité à monter
sur la scène guyancourt toise on est
content de jouer déjà et en plus quand
c'est pour une bonne cause c'est encore
mieux c'est pas vraiment s'engager pour
un événement ces deux commandes ya des
présents et puis de faire risquer
quelque chose derrière pour toi tu
sèches pourrait détourner
je marchais droit
on a déjà fait des concerts entre
guillemets de soutien à d'autres causes
aussi
enfin la musique c'est un chouette
vecteur pour pour rassembler des gens
autour d'une idée quatre associations
ont pu récupérer les deux cents jouets
récoltés lors de cette soirée
ils seront distribués pour noël aux
enfants dans le besoin